but the horizontal line test tests for
is if the inverse of a graph or the
inverse of an equation is a function so
what you do is you take a horizontal
line like this marker here and you scan
from low to high like this and you see
if the horizontal line crosses the graph
at more than one point so you can see
here it's only crossing at once once
once once so this passes the horizontal
line test it means that the inverse of
this graph will be a function the
vertical line test test to see if this
graph itself is a function and you can
see that it would fail it would be
crossing at more than one point but when
you draw the horizontal line test a test
to see if the inverse of this graphs a
function which it is this one here if we
draw a horizontal line as we scan from
low to high you can see it's crossing at
more than one point so that means that
the inverse of this graph is not a
function this graph itself passes the
vertical line test this graph is a
function but its inverse would not be a
function same thing here
horizontal line test passes there but
you can see it fails there so as we scan
from low to high take a horizontal line
if it crosses at more than one point
here you can see it's actually crossing
at three that fails the horizontal line
test that means that this graph its
inverse is not a function just